je voudrais souligner par ailleurs que
la procédure qui était une mise en place
par le législateur et que et que vous
êtes pour rendre depuis y ait deux tubes
sont maintenant exclus d'une procédure
complexe il ya tout d'abord un enjeu de
sécurité juridique fort qui nous apporte
parce que évidemment il faut entourer de
décision de la la de toutes les
garanties juridiques nécessaires pour
pouvoir mener à son terme cette
procédure je rappelle que c'est une
procédure dite accélérée au fou qui est
une nouvelle en réalité et qui n'est pas
une procédure en référé donc qu'ils
répondent pas aux mêmes conditions
notamment de délai par ailleurs vous le
vous le savez les sites qui sont
indirectement ambitions d'une fille née
visées par ces procédures je parle des
sites pornographiques
se sont entourés de des meilleurs
conseils des meilleurs avocats de la
place de paris et sont d'une approche
qui colle on peut qualifier de
contentieux à notre égard vous savez
d'ailleurs cet égard que ils ont d'ores
et déjà
attaqué le décret d'application de la
loi et que dans les écritures récente
que nous avons que nous avons reçues il
multiplie les actes aux tensions puisque
ils entendent poser une question
préjudicielle aux jeunes européens est
ainsi qu'une question de prix
littéraires de constitutionnalité qui
selon eux doit être soumise au conseil
constitutionnel
donc il est vraiment essentiel pour nous
et pour la bonne mise en oeuvre de la
loi que nous aurions de d2 de procédures
juridiques les plus éprouvés c'est ce
qui nous a conduit d'ailleurs
dans la première phase de mise en oeuvre
de ce texte à recouvrir les constats
d'huissier vous l'aidez souligne la
présidente c'est une procédure qui est
plus longue évidemment mais qui encore
le fond de ces garanties
nos effectifs ont malgré tout à l'avenir
à recourir à des procédures plus souples
plus rapide plus efficace qui nous
permettront de traiter plus rapidement
les autres saisine et les autres sites
qui sont notamment
visé par les associations que lesquels
nous discutons très régulièrement je
voudrais également souligner que c'est
une procédure qui entre en scène de
révéler qu'ils sont eux-mêmes
relativement loin encore une fois je le
dis c'est pas une procédure en référé je
vous donne un exemple lorsqu on assigne
un fournisseur d'accès internet en
outre-mer il faut un mois nous sommes
par ailleurs bien sûr les dates
d'audiences automnale fixée par le juge
judiciaire et c'est bien normal et
doivent tenir compte de l'ensemble des
désastres qui se présente devant le juge
et cela prend vous l'avez les régions
entre entre deux et trois mois selon les
différentes étapes de la procédure que
nous est décrite et puis enfin il est
aussi indiqué
nous sommes deux soumis à des
contraintes procédurales dans le cadre
de l'union européenne puisque du fait de
l'application du principe du pays
d'origine qui qui est inscrit dans la
directive e-commerce nous devons non
seulement informé l'état membre où il a
établi le dit a décidé vous savez
excessifs sont établis dans des étangs
des états membres de l'union européenne
nous devons informer l'état membre de la
procédure que nous engageons lui
demander s'ils comptent mettre en oeuvre
les mêmes les actions à l'égard de ces
sites et parallèlement nous devons
informer la commission européenne
donc encore une fois c'est une c'est une
procédure qui qui nécessite un certain
nombre de garanties
[Musique]